71 and 36
has the bro the nets to a 23 and 12
record and quinn the debut of one of the
most talented players you'll find kyrie
irving the debut of one of the top 10
easy players in this league i mean if
the circumstances are different there's
no question about that then the pacers
are just gonna have to be hurting lineup
that the nets have had
this season
meanwhile for indiana they're dealing
with a lot of players in health and
safety protocols will get you updated as
the action continues
kyrie irving
first game since june the 10th
when he suffered that ankle injury
against the bucks in the eastern
conference semifinals
eligible to appear in road games only
and here he is in indiana starting for
the nets tonight james williams tyler
ford isaac barnett the officiating crew
brooklyn controls the tip
that's trying to snap a three-game
losing streak they defeated
indiana earlier this season come from
behind win irving behind the back
off the rim
out of bounds well say this much it is
just so good to see kyrie irving back on
the floor playing basketball
he is such a special talent and i like
that out of the gates he's getting
comfortable he's getting loose and he's
taking a quick look